what inspires me is to try to answer the
question the most important questions
about public opinion next week the
question will be what is the public's
reaction of the Petraeus report doing a
good job of covering the way the public
has reacted to what President Bush and
General Petraeus have said about the
surgeon and the course of our of our
future troops troops in in Iraq is what
what inspires well you know this is both
an art and a science in its science
scientific aspects of this devout
determine the sampling and the
analytical to some of the analytical to
statistically analyze tools we use in
terms of writing the questions and
drawing conclusions from that the data
that has to do with one's how good one
is as an analyst we have a lot of
material just as in any scientific
venture and we have a lot of data and a
good deal of the skill is what we can
make out of it how coherent and
defensible and authentic a replicable a
case can we make for the conclusions
that we come to about public opinion
you